for the past several weeks people of
both parties have been talking about how
we need police reform and probably those
calls are overblown but there's there's
certainly some truth to that I mean the
police simply should always be reforming
because they have a monopoly on the use
of power and it's a good thing for them
to be trained to know exactly what to do
the thing is the cops get their training
and a lot of citizens don't get their
training I had a buddy of mine who
actually was a cop himself and at one
time he was flying down the road he was
everywhere he was Arizona or something
like that he was speeding speeding right
he gets pulled over and the cop thought
he might be a drug runner or something
he was going over a hundred miles an
hour something like that and they got
into a very tense situation and my buddy
who write doesn't check any of the boxes
that people are talking about these days
he was a white guy he was a cop ex-cop
himself he still knew it was a very
tense situation that caught the other
cop who was arresting him had his weapon
drawn he says you got to watch out go
slowly and the guy my friend is yelling
after the window I don't have a weapon
on my hands are up and and they avoided
what could have been a very sad
situation but obviously everyone is on
edge in these kind of altercations the
reason my friend was okay was because he
had been trained of exactly what to do
in those situations when you get pulled
over by a cop we don't train our
citizens anymore of any color really but
obviously the focus right now in in
these past few weeks has been on the
racial dimension of getting pulled over
we don't train our citizens anymore on
how to interact with cops and then out
of the blue I found this clip from the
Chris Rock show in Oz probably 1997 or
1998 where Chris Rock makes this exact
point in an extremely politically
incorrect way that is doubtless going to
get him canceled here's Chris Rock if
you follow these easy tips you'll be
fine first obey the law laws were made
for a reason think of them as hints you
heard people say man I wouldn't do that
if I was you well here's some of that
carjacking Oh
robbery awesome selling drugs buying
drugs stabbing shooting you know you
probably won't get your kick if you just
use common sense if you jump a subway
turnstile
you might just get off with a warning
from the police but if you jump a
turnstile carrying a loaded gun and
smoking a joint so goes on and on you
get the point obviously now that I've
played this it's unfortunate for Chris
Rock but he's gonna be maligned as a
white supremacist and a neo-nazi and a
racist he's gonna get cancelled which is
too bad cuz I like Chris Rock makes a
very good point it actually shows us
something about our culture we used to
be able to joke about these things talk
about these things with some kind of
balance no more that's we seem too
afraid too much at this point and I
wonder if it's because we keep on buying
into these small little lies the lie
that there is a systemic scourge of
racist cops slaughtering innocent black
men in the country which just isn't
happening every death is a tragedy but
we don't have evidence of this systemic
kind of slaughter and you buy into these
lies because they seem nice and
sentimental and well what could the
consequences be well the consequences
now are we've got a culture where cops
are walking out of the precinct to
unmask because they don't want to have
their lives ruined and everyone is at
each other's throats and we're burning
down cities and we've got occupied
villages in Chad's and chop and Somalia
and whatever it is in Seattle and nobody
can laugh at anything and everybody's
getting canceled I think it's cuz we're
buying all those tiny little lies were
throwing common sense out the window
that's Chris Rock's offering of a little
bit of common sense probably though
unfortunately these days it'll fall on
deaf ears
[Music]
[Music]